so bin ich einfach so bin ich einfach
ist ja auch ein spruch wenig wirklich
oft höre aber noch manche und doch war
da von mir auch doch das noch nie im
leben habe ich dass das nicht die sieben
wege zur effektivität das ist so ein
ratgeber und das hört sich so blöd an
dieses effektivität ist ein wort was
sich irgendwie so ein bisschen ablehne
deswegen bin ich mit großer skepsis an
das buch heran gegangen
dann habe ich aber rein gelesen und muss
sagen also blöd ist das ganze überhaupt
nicht was mich überrascht hat ist das
ist ja dann doch auch so um eine gewisse
ganzheitlichkeit geht es ist nicht im
sinne von hauptsache man wird
effizienter natürlich war das ist ja
also wir dürfen nicht effizienz mit
effektivität verwechseln effektivität
sagt einfach nur ich habe ein ziel mir
gesteckt und ich habe das erreicht in
einer bestimmten qualität in einem
bestimmten genuss macht und dafür
plädiert er natürlich auch dass man sich
überhaupt ziele setzt wenn wir von
effektivität wo bleiben die vergeudung
improvisierte hoch ist doch eigentlich
jedoch auch wichtig sind für die genaue
menge durch absolutes doch das
repräsentative für solche ratgeber dass
sie immer versuchen das leben zu
verbessern im sinne von performance man
soll sich ja auch pläne an fertigen
darüber sein was macht im körper denken
drin dass das grauenhaft das ist auch
einer der gründe weshalb ratgeber bei
mir überhaupt keine chance haben weil ob
es sporternährung selbstoptimierung
meditation und auch keine chance bei mir
und du kommst immer und sagt macht war
nur hallo dann sage ich nach all den
jahren war hieß es
naja ich werde nicht aufgeben im
vergleich zu gewissen anderen ratgebern
die wir auch schon hatten es ist mehr
formell ausgelegt aber es ist weniger
materiell aus dass der koffer denen man
bekommt um damit sein eigenes profil zu
erstellen und weiter zu treiben
insofern gehört das zu den ratgebern die
ich mit größerem interesse mir
angeschaut habe als andere wo ich leicht
geheime langzeitwirkungen ich bin
gespannt so bin ich einfach so bin ich
einfach ist ja auch ein spruch den ich
wirklich oft höre aber noch manche doch
noch nie in meinem leben habe ich das
alles nicht und gar nicht zumal jetzt
auch damit dass uns da sagst du zu mir
nicht so bin ich
sondern du sagst ich kann eine andere
herangehensweise denen ich kann auch die
möglichkeit wählen jetzt hier von diesem
hocker zu verduften weil ich einfach
langsam genug habe gute idee auf
wiedersehen jedoch jedoch
[Gelächter]
[Musik]